[Applause]
are you gonna play it
I always slay it Queen don't know what
any of that means don't be left out
anymore
watch new episodes of the best comedy
show round Rick and Morty five all-new
episodes starts Sunday November 10th at
11:30 only on Adult Swim
[Music]
it's been way too long
sooner the smartest brick and Martius
morty in the universe are back i'm
operated to climb something this year
look you're the guy that wanted an epic
adventure I'm the guy with only one huh
birds are pretty much I don't know I'm
just usually around people that die
faster Rick and Morty five all-new
episodes starts Sunday November 10th at
11:30 half the season you deserve oh the
season we could handle you know what
this one counts as one of your
adventures only on Adult Swim welcome
back everyone it's Charlie they dropped
a new promo for season four this is also
going to be my non-spoilery review of
Rick and Morty's season 4 episode 1 I
had a chance to see the episode early I
will be doing videos for all the
episodes this season so be sure to
subscribe if you're brand new to my
channel I'll do merch giveaways and all
the videos all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest prediction about evil Morty
during season 4 and don't worry there is
more than five episodes total in season
4 it's just that the first five are
airing before the end of the year I'll
explain how that's gonna work at the end
of the video but the long wait for
season four is over we're finally there
you guys made it if you've been a fan of
rick and morty since the beginning then
giant breaks between seasons is no big
deal you're used to it by now but one of
the results of the giant break since
season 3 in the 70's ode renewal was
this real desire from Dan Harmon and
Justin roiland based on what they've
said to prove to fans that the show
deserves all the popularity that it's
gained and that despite the gaping
chasms of breaks between seasons they
have not lost any of their edge or wit
one of the best things about the show
the last couple of years has been
watching how much more complex and crazy
the stories of God as they started to
polish their creative process and found
their quote-unquote special sauce in the
writers room make all the Szechuan jokes
you want the animation has always been
solid the only minor changes you notice
when
go back and re-watch season 1 is that
between seasons 1 of season 2 they fix
some of the framerate issues but Bardell
for the most part have been their
animators since season 1 and as far as I
know they'll continue to do so until the
show goes off the air after a hundred
years worth of seasons but season four
episode 1 is titled Rick die repeat edge
of temor T which is a reference to Tom
Cruise's edge of tomorrow movie which
itself is based on a Japanese manga
called all you need is kill in the
episode also borrows the main premise of
the movie that Tom Cruise gets caught in
a resurrection time loop and winds up
dying a thousand times until he finds
all the different things that he needs
to do so that he can end the time loop
and his life can finally move forward in
the basic concept of episode 1 without
getting too spoilery about it is that
Rick and Morty finds something that
allows them to see their future and see
how they're going to die and Rick who's
not only aware that he's in a fictional
TV show so why does anything matter has
also shown countless times that he has
no problem with dying in no real
attachment to his current physical form
he's not a total nihilist he does care
about things he cares about Morty he
cares about Beth he cares about the
family but like season 3 episode 6 is a
good example
fighting toxic Rick he made a new body
for himself mid fight and didn't skip a
beat or project Phoenix from tiny Rick
not the fallback he thought it was he
destroys all of his clones like it's no
big deal there's no great existential
crisis at knowing his future because
he's traveled the finite curb and seen
hundreds and thousands of different
versions of himself all who made very
different choices and have wildly
different lives than he did is the same
basic concept as the message of
interdimensional cable he doesn't get so
hung up on what he might have done when
things go wrong his main concern remains
his immediate survival through the
episode it's Morty that really flips out
when he finds out how he's going to die
and can't get past it he's consumed like
Tom Cruise was in changing his fate and
trying all kinds of different things to
avoid it he's still a little kid so he
doesn't quite understand the concept of
self-fulfilling prophecies it's a lot
like Morty during more T's mind blowers
he stares into the truth tortoises eyes
and suddenly he literally knows
everything as his mind starts to
collapse under the stress of it all
until Rick explains how he's kept Morty
sane during all their escalating
adventures by erasing the most dangerous
memories the difference this time in
season 4 episode 1 because Dan and
Justin aren't super huge on copy-paste
repeating storylines is that there's no
super quick fix that Rick can use on
Morty he has to just deal with it in
Rick's message the ultimate message of
the episode is to just be content to
live in the present don't get so caught
up on what might happen that it prevents
you from being happy which if you've
ever listened to an episode of Harmon
town you might hear Dan Harmon talking
about all the time it's something that
he gets hung up on in real life his own
fear of eventually maybe being destitute
so he works harder and harder and
sometimes will get super stuck on things
so the message of the episode also kind
of winds up being the writers commenting
on themselves in a meta way and you'll
remember part of the reason for the
major delay between season 2 and season
3 is that Dan Harmon said that they
would be times in the writers room that
they just get stuck on an idea or a
script for way too long and it would
prevent them from finishing things on
time it was even a trailer video that I
did last week where Justin and Dan were
making fun of themselves for blowing all
their deadlines when they were working
on season 4 episodes we missed all of
our deadlines season 4 episode 1 isn't
the first time the writers have used
episodes to joke or comment about
themselves in real life
also during Morty's mind blowers the
ending scene where summers forced to
save Rick and Morty after they pull a
scenario for they wake up thinking that
they missed a new interdimensional cable
episode yelling it's summer and she says
no wonder you're constantly fighting
with each other in behind schedule the
things they were referencing with that
particular scene was mostly the false
accusation that the writers spent most
of season 3 fighting with each other
particularly dan and Justin in that's
why season 3 came so late which is only
half true they did get hung up on script
details but they weren't fighting or at
each other's throats or anything like
that talking about big changes from
season 3 the most seismic change between
season 3 and season 4 just in terms of
the story is the family dynamic itself
they foreshadow that themselves during
the season 3 episode 10 ending scene the
finale when Beth says things are going
to be more like they were during seasons
1 and seasons 2 they also released a new
promo image that kind of conveys what
that looks like in the episodes with
Jerry yelling at Rick
in Rick's standing they're being forced
to listen to him at the beginning of
season 4 Rick is kind of low man on the
totem pole again in terms of family
status despite being smarter and better
than ever so at least in the first
episode because I haven't seen the other
ones yet they do address this by having
Rick at least try to get some measure of
consent to take Morty on their next
adventure instead of just dragging him
out of bed like he wouldn't previous
seasons or ordering people to come along
with them as you can see even though
he's not happy about it he still tries
to get permission and you guys get
really excited by this just like at the
end of every single first episode from
each season at the end of season 4
episode 1 there's a huge fourth wall
break moment that's even bigger and
crazier in scope than the season 3
episode one Szechuan sauce rant just to
let you know that despite the super long
break between seasons they have huge
huge plans for the show and things will
only get more epic and crazier over the
next 69 episodes but just ranking my
favorite premiere episodes there haven't
been that many so this is actually
pretty easy going from bottom to top
starting with number 4 season 1 episode
1 it was great as a polished version of
the doc and Marty original short that
Justin made that would later turn into
Rick and Morty but it's more of a proof
of concept for the series there's a
thousand percent more burps and they
repeat each other's names constantly if
you haven't watched it in a while it's
still a really fun episode I still
really like it but the show's gotten way
more polished since then number three
season 2 episode 1 this was also a
seismic change in terms of how crazy the
science fiction of the show got but also
a huge increase in the heart the core
story telling Rick's relationship with
his family it also gave us one of the
best Rick moments of all time he
sacrifices himself only to then take his
promise to God right back and throw it
in his face after surviving it perfectly
encapsulates who Rick Sanchez is as a
person
or at least c-137 Rick my number 2 is
season 3 episode 1 you're probably
sensing the pattern here but last
season's premiere came after the longest
break between seasons up to that point
not only did they deliver on increased
fan expectation with one of the crazier
plots and sci-fi twist so far they also
used those twists to kind of answer a
lot of long-running fan questions then
take it all right back what is Rick's
origin story what happened to his wife
one of the biggest fan questions since
the
beginning but the show is always at its
best when it doesn't over explain things
in Rick is more interesting when you
don't know everything about his
backstory they also when major bonus
points for that April Fool's Day stunt
episode that was really cool
so why obviously season four episode one
is my favorite season premiere so far
I'm not quite ready to call it my
favorite episode of all time but it is
amazing and even though it sucks that it
took this long to get to season four the
show is just as good as it's ever been
if not better yes I know everyone still
freaked out about that five episode run
but remember there's just a short break
for the holidays then they come back for
more episodes for the rest of the season
reason the you're getting five and then
a small break and then the back five is
because Turner Broadcasting warned us
about entertainment signal levels my
full season 4 episode 1 video will post
next Monday morning as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see the videos when I post them but
leave all your video requests in the
comments below
congratulations GT god bear you're the
giveaway winner for my last Rick and
Morty video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details
everyone click here for that last big
Rick and Morty season 4 trailer with a
bunch of new clips and footage and click
here for all my Rick and Morty season 3
episode videos and Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]